salut brut c'est pedro winter & mid le
mec musique vivra plus simple à ces
revêtements cette interview vous savez
me up salut brut pas pop c'est pas mal
ça lui brûle ses pôles winter et vous
êtes chez bond girl en compagnie de mid
manson ou également avec one will avec
je fais souvent les règles je vais vous
confesser un truc brut parce qu'on est
entre nous personne ne regarde je
connais pas les paroles de baby i'm
yours
ds je galère un peu et the sun
maintenant vous même vous avez sûr je
vais les attendre
mais les chansons club les gens ne
connaissent pas les paroles il coupe le
son pendant les dj sets et il marmonne
ils sont super contents de juste
marmonné la mélodie très fort dans un
club mais ça suffit affirme ambiance non
à une époque
bon je fais encore temps en temps quand
le jeu mais je jouais en soldat comme
ils s'appellent da funk et je faisais
chantait la foule
j'ai coupé son élan il atteint
voilà c'était un petit moment tajik
alors notre première rencontre moi j'ai
un souvenir de toi quand corne à passer
un peu de temps ensemble aux philippines
tout à fait on s'est retrouvé là bardon
n'était pas c'était bien avant que je
rejoigne la famille de vang heures mais
ont joué dans le même festival à l'autre
à l'autre bout du monde amani exactement
un festival un peu pourri pour
totalement est on va pas vendre du rêve
aux gens de wes était générale dont il a
fait le tour du monde
c'était un festival un peu fiasco pas de
notre faute hein mais ça qu'on appelle
c'est la première fois qu'on a passé un
peu de temps ensemble et de fil en
aiguille son c'est ton équipe les
recettes ont management qui m'a appelé
on en vient
mais de fait des trucs tout seul
maintenant et il a fait un morceau et on
pense que ça pourrait être pas mal en
tout cas sur ed banger et effectivement
je suis tombé tout de suite
suchart vu taper à la porte vitrée de
chez ed banger pour venir faire écouter
ses morceaux et je me suis assis en face
assez impressionné la première fois
parce que quand on fait écouter des
morceaux
même si on a déjà fait ça mille fois
dans sa vie c'est toujours assez
impressionnant et puis on a écouté ça
ici et au but pedro n'a rien dit je
crois que c'est une technique de deux
mecs de lamelles de bois rond c'est une
technique de rien dire de faire et bien
c'est vrai que je fais ça tu as dit très
bien allongé maintenant on est allé
manger on n'a pas parlé musique du tout
et une semaine plus tard il m'a rappelée
en disant c'est parti pour l'aventuré
mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya d'autres de plus
important que la bouffe sans déconner
c'est qu'est-ce que justice c'était une
raclette boston bonne c'était une
saucisse purée pas très loin toi je vois
son a dit n'être déjeuner on a mangé
j'ai une frappe végétarien chez soul
kitchen a pas mal abbas avait rejeté
mais bien c'est au soleil
tu m'a tapé dans l'oeil ah mais oui je
m'en souviens maintenant ok c'est très
bon signe et mais non mais qu'est ce que
tu veux je te dise moi non c'était pas
du tout une tactique particulière de
rien dire un artiste en tout comme avait
passé une semaine extrêmement mauvaise
qu'elle sache maintenant après coup bah
oui parce que c'est j'ai eu un premier
test qui ne me rappelais pas donc j'ai
mis un peu de temps tu as mis une
semaine ouais je suis un mec occupé mais
je sais c'est possible bah oui de bafé
drôle il ya une passion pour pour tout
ce qui est charcuterie ans c'est un truc
à chaque fois qu'on va quelque part il
ya bientôt cinq six tranches de jambon
locaux donc moi je directement je dirais
une charcutier pas mal pas mal moi
j'aurais fait un truc un peu plus -
terre-à-terre et moi réel là dessus des
tutus des voix des petits du jardin
secret quand même mais je pense que mon
fils on pourrait tous les deux que ce
que j'aime bien rejoindre les colliers
les choses je pense quand tous les deux
on pourrait être bon dans un club med
tu vois on serait de bon j'ai au jeu
bien que le chef du village parce que
j'aime le chef mais je sais que je
pourrai toujours compter sur toi tout
seul chef des jets aux infirmiers mois
ah bon ouais je sais pas et je vous
ferez soigner parce qu'il fallait dans
un club med en juin et le linge amis
avaient le droit de conduire la petite
voiturette de golf pour aller sauver les
gens évidemment ça me donne
un truc en plus moi je te propose des
chefs des géo donc tu veux être un
fermier une petite bouille l'histoire de
google fait j'ai le coeur sur la main
j'ai besoin d'aider l'autre pas très
ambitieux tout ça l'album pour écrire
l'autre ça peut être une parole sur
musique là mais alors tu sais quoi c'est
incroyable que tu me demande ça parce
que évidemment regarde là on est chez le
vendeur il est des 10 partout et tu me
tend une perche et le disque parfait
[Musique]
mise si jamais elle devait offrir un
disque je t'offre est un des premiers
albums que j'ai acheté de ma vie je
crois que c'était mais elle en 1986 ou
quelque chose comme ça frankie goes to
hollywood
welcome to de pleasure dome qu'est
vraiment à mes albums préférés il ya
même mon nom c'est ma grand mère qu'elle
a écrit mon nom dessus
donc je te prête parce que pour la
caméra je te fais dire je te donne mais
tu me le rend après merci ces genres d
un mes albums préférés ever et je ne
veux pas prévu un ta question tombe
comme ça et le disque était juste là et
ben moi je vais vous devez de comparer
un personnage je te compare à ronald
mcdonald a pas mal qui en fait chef de
si on connaît bien le tout la l'univers
mac donald's la mythologie de la
mythologie mag la ligue 1 il ya chez big
band qui est plutôt sympathique
en même temps il représente une marque
bon après on aime ou on n'aime pas mais
j'aime bien évident loeffel il est dans
le plaisir et elle nous accueille chez
lui
ronald très bon choix merci de vos frais
lundi ce qui est à moi c'est mieux